let's say we've got the function f of x
is equal to e to the x and just to get a
sense of what that looks like let me do
a rough drawing of f of x is equal to e
to the x
it would look something like this it
would look something like that
so that is e to the x
and what i want to do is i want to
approximate f of x is equal to e to the
x using a taylor series approximation or
taylor series expansion and i want to do
it not around x is equal to zero i want
to do it around x is equal to three just
to pick another arbitrary value so we're
going to do it around x is equal to
three this is x is equal to three
this right there that is f of three f of
three is e to the third power so this is
e to the third power right over there
so when we take the taylor series
expansion if we have if we have a zero
degree polynomial approximating it the
best we could probably do is have a
constant function going straight through
e to the third if we do a first if we do
a a a first order approximation so we
have a first degree term then it will be
the tangent line
if we add and as we add more and more
degrees to it we should hopefully be
able to
kind of contour or converge with the
curve better and better and better in
the future we'll talk a little bit more
about how we can test for convergences
and how well are we converging and all
of that type of thing but with that said
let's just apply the formula that
hopefully got the intuition for in the
last video so the the taylor series
expansion for f of x is equal to e to
the x will be
the polynomial so what's f of c
well if x is equal to 3 we're saying
that c is 3 in this situation so if c is
3 f of 3 is e to the third power so it's
e to the third power plus
what's f prime of c well f prime of x is
also going to be e to the x you take the
derivative of e to the x you get e to
the x that's one of the super cool
things about e to the x
so this is also f prime of x frankly
this is the same thing as f
the nth derivative of x you can just
keep taking the derivative of this and
you'll get e to the x so f prime of x is
e to the x you evaluate that at 3 you
get e to the third power again times x
minus three c is three
plus
the second derivative of our function is
still e to the x evaluate that at three
you get e to the third power
over two factorial times x minus three
to the second power and then we could
keep going the third derivative is still
e to the x evaluate that at three c is
three in this situation so you get e to
the third power over three factorial
times x minus 3 to the third power and
we can keep going with this but i think
you get the general idea but what's even
more interesting than just kind of going
through the mechanics of finding the
expansion is seeing how it how as we add
more and more terms it starts to
approximate e to the x better and better
better and our approximation gets good
further and further away from x is equal
to three and to do that i used wool from
alpha available at wolfram
wolframalpha.com
and i think i typed in like taylor
series expansion e to the x and x equals
three and i just knew what i wanted and
gave me all of this business right over
here and actually calculated the
expansion you can see it's the exact
same thing that we have over here e to
the third plus e to the third times x
minus three
we have e to the third plus e to the
third times x minus three plus one half
they actually expanded out the factorial
so instead of three factorial they wrote
a 6 over here and they did a bunch of
terms up here but it's even more
interesting is that they actually graph
each of these each of these
each of these polynomials with more and
more terms so in orange we have e to the
x we have f of x is equal to e to the x
and then they tell us
order and approximation shown with n
dots so
the order one approximation so that
should be the that should be the
situation where we have a first degree
polynomial so that's literally a first
degree polynomial would be these two
terms right over here because this is a
zeroth degree this is a first degree we
just have x to the first power involved
here that will be if we just were to
plot this if this was our polynomial
that is plotted with one dot and that is
this one right over here with one dot
and they plot it
they plot it right over here and we can
see that it's just a tangent line at at
x is equal to 3 that is x is equal to 3
right over there and so this is the
tangent line
if we add a term now now we're getting
to a second degree polynomial because
we're adding an x squared if you expand
this out you'll have an x squared term
and you'll have another x term but the
degree of the polynomial will now be a
second degree so let's look for two dots
so that's this one right over here so
let's see two dots
two dots coming in so you'll notice one
two dots so you have two dots and it
comes in
and this is a a parabola it's a second
degree polynomial and then it comes back
like this but notice it does a better
job especially around x equals three of
approximating e to the x it stays with
the curve a little bit longer
you add another term
you add another term let me just in a
new color a color that i have not used
you add another term now you have a
third degree polynomial if you have all
of these combined if this is your
polynomial
and you were to graph that so let's look
for the three dots right over here so
one two three so it's this curve
third degree polynomial
is this curve right over here and notice
it starts contouring e to the x a little
bit sooner than the second degree
version and it stays with it a little
bit longer
it stays with it a little bit longer and
so you have it just like that you add
another term to it you add the fourth
degree term to it so now we have all of
this plus all of this
if this is your polynomial now you have
this curve right over here notice every
time you add a term it's getting better
and better at approximating e to the x
further and further away from x is equal
to three and then if you add another
term you get this term this one up here
but hopefully that satisfies you that we
are getting closer and closer the more
terms we add so you could imagine it's a
pretty darn good approximation as we
approach adding an infinite an infinite
number of terms